flamenco is a combination of melancholic
tones and fiery passion it's a kind of
marriage of music and dance one of the
places to discover the culture behind
flamenco is in Granada a city that for
centuries was governed by Arab rulers
their residence is the city's landmark
the Alhambra and Arabic music has left
its mark on the culture many famous
flamenco dancers and musicians come from
here here in Granada I want to dance the
buleria which is a joyful version of
flamenco very popular among non
professional dancers I myself have been
dancing flamenco for some years and now
I'm looking forward to get a flamenco
lesson from an Andalusian Pro Maria's
dance school is in a district called
sacromonte a Spanish for Holy Mountain
it was once home to the Sinti and Roma
who emigrated here and put their stamp
on flamenco in caves no less and that's
where the dance school is located
[Music]
Violeta burries has been a professional
flamenco dancer since she was 16 she's
performed across Spain as well as abroad
her father was a well-known flamenco
guitarist pinguin say yet Violeta we're
dancing the buleria but why in a cave
bueno por aquí los Medanos Viviana
castanos lived in caves in the 19th
century they sang and danced here people
visiting the caves stopped by to see
this artform and at some point they
started tipping for it haruna alguna
manera de Noronha pro Pina yeah so
that's where flamenco started yes they
start with clapping for their rhythm
which is in beats of 12
[Applause]
there are typical buleria steps but
there's no set sequence the dancer is
supposed to improvise it's clear that
Maria has some experience with the dance
otherwise she probably wouldn't be able
to keep up and soon she's flying solo
practicing the basic step helps before
moving on to something more advanced
Violeta wants things to be more playful
she encourages Maria to let go a bit
more buleria is supposed to be at ease
without taking things too seriously
all right great perfect ha so we've
practiced the dance what else do I need
you to think of it okay me faster
they've all got music it's the most
important thing in flamenco Eddie listen
to the singing and guitar so you know
when to start dancing where to put the
absence and when to finish antonio el
torre also improvises when he plays and
sings
the vocal signal Maria's entrance but
she missed it haha Violetta helps her
listen better this time it works and she
goes for it the pool area is a solo
dance because it has a more cheerful
tone it's usually the last dance of a
flamenco show ok at the hardiness
Desiree of Lamia Cobar there's live
music and dancing every evening such
venues are common in Granada Violeta is
both a dancer and the manager here
[Applause]
and after her performance it's Maria's
turn she comes in a little late but
loosens up a bit and goes with the flow
[Applause]
my malaria wasn't that good but I
enjoyed dancing I improvised and that's
also what lemon goes about early the
dance challenge is over
so now Maria can simply enjoy the rest
of the evening